[Music]  three person seeing Brian James all  touchy-feely it doesn't seem real but  seeing it in real life  it's I guess it's real Bryan Tanaka  getting jealous watching Mariah Carey  cozy up to her now ex-fiance James  Packer on Sunday's episode of Mariah's  world this is like a big reality check  took a lot of air out of my balloon it  just sucks  James flies to Paris to watch Mariah  perform and celebrate the launch of her  new vodka I felt like there was  something kind of there then you know  James came into town and he's never  around like I've never really seen them  together really but all episode long  Brian was coming to a big realization  that he wanted more from me me  all rise type of woman that I see myself  with you know the more time we spend  together  it just feels like we're getting closer  and closer especially when he saw her in  her wedding dress see him Ryan a dress  it's definitely a wake-up call cuz I'm  like oh yeah wedding  [Music]  you